it
you
welcome again beloved to this Gathering of
Henderson Hills Baptist Church. My name is John and it's
great to see you as we continue in this Advent Series
this Christmas series that word
Advent remember simply means coming or appearing.
And so this this is looking back to those faithful
Saints of olds who are awaiting for the Messiah to
come and they were looking ahead and waiting on his Advent his
appearing and so we we identify with them
yet in this season. We're also still awaiting something
ourselves.
That's Christ's second Advent at the end his second
appearing when all will be made, right?
And so these symbols and in these words that were studying in
this season are meant to create in us and
anticipation.
Both for what we celebrate in a couple weeks that incarnation of
of God In the Flesh Jesus coming
as a baby. We celebrate that
we're awaiting that but it also should point
us forward to that second coming.
When we will see all of of
the the things we're waiting for happen in
full form that's already in some part, but it's not
yet fully finished. And so we wait
for that.
And that should lead us to live our lives differently
today.
And so to get there we have taken this
Advent series to look at five different words.
This is traditionally throughout the generations the same kind
of idea that these five words exemplify what
they were waiting for back then but also
what we're waiting for in full.
And each candle on this Reef will symbolize one of
those words represent one of those words.
And we light a new one each week as you'll see a little
bit later and we started this last Wednesday night where we
lighted the candle of hope that Jesus
fulfills the hope of every longing
heart both in part now, but in full in
the future, if you miss that one, you can go back on our website
on the app. You can go watch that one from Wednesday night to
catch up.
But today building off of that. Hope we will
look at how Jesus is the Peace of every
longing heart. So take your copy
of God's word and turn to the book of Ephesians to see that.
Ephesians chapter 2 in the New Testament Ephesians most
of the way through
Big Book of Romans
first second Corinthians Galatians Ephesians chapter
2 verses 11 through 22
Again, our word today is peace.
How Jesus is the Peace of every longing heart?
now one way to define a word is to lay out
a series of antonyms or words
that mean the exact opposite of what the word means
and so you can kind of get a feel for what it does mean and so what's
contrary to peace
Well, like Tolstoy said of course, it's War right
War and Peace, but but there's more to it.
The opposite of of peace is also division.
We're worried.
hate
chaos
stress
those are all opposites of peace. There's a lot of different meanings to
the word. Peace. So there's a lot of different antonyms to the same
word.
But at the essence of every definition of peace
Is the Old Testament Hebrew word shalom?
Shalom you might have heard of before.
It's a word that means complete.
were whole
think of a stone that has perfectly
whole shape with no cracks through
it.
Or think of a brick wall that has no gaps.
And no missing bricks. It's complete.
The Bible project says the Shalom refers to something that's complex
with lots of pieces, but is
in a state of completeness or wholeness.
So imagine that 1,000 piece puzzle that
you and your family are going to work on over Christmas break, right?
You got whether that's like kittens or baby Yoda or
something, whatever you've got that you you dump that box
out and and you you know that that's that's in
chaos, right?
Just all the pieces strewn all over the place. But what do you
do you start to bring Shalom to the
puzzle?
Turn all the pieces over right side up so you can see the colors you separate
the edge pieces out you start to do the frame of
the puzzle. And then you start to match
the picture on the box with what you're doing
down here until it's complete.
shalom
kind of like that with our extremely complex lives, right?
Our Shalom breaks down when relationships
are out of alignment or
when situations are out of alignment or when things
are missing in our lives and things break down. It's
chaos. That is
out of peace
It's when you don't feel peaceful, right when all
these things are going on, and it's not as it should
be.
When life is no longer whole whenever it needs
to be restored in some way when you feel chaos.
It's a lack of peace.
And so what do you do you try to bring shalom?
To your life by I got to finish that project. I
need to repay that someone that I've I've heard or
there's a loss. I got to pay that back or or relationship that's
broken. I need to restore that so we
can flourish together. Like that's what you start to do.
You start to bring Shalom you go about trying to make things whole
again.
but the nonchaloam that Brokenness
is where we find ourselves here in Ephesians 2.
Now right before the section will study Paul had just described the
beauty of individual salvation by grace through faith
in Jesus.
But in verses 11 through 22 here, he applies that
same gospel to the whole body.
To how it shows up.
with a group
Here it is verses 11 through 22. Listen.
Therefore just because of the Gospel remember that at
one time you Gentiles in the flesh called
the uncircumcision by what is called the circumcision, which
is made in the flesh by hands. Remember that you
were at that time separated from Christ alienated from
the common wealth of Israel strangers to the covenants of
Promise having no hope without God in the
world.
But now in Christ Jesus you were once far off
have been brought near by the blood of Christ for he himself
is our peace.
Who has made us both one has broken down in his flesh the
dividing wall of hostility by abolishing the
law of Commandments expressed in ordinances.
That he might create in himself one new man in
place of the two so making peace.
And might reconcile us both to God in one body through the
cross.
thereby killing the hostility
and he came and preached peace to you who are far
off and peace to those who were near.
For through him we both have access in one
Spirit to the father.
So then you are no longer strangers and Aliens, but you are fellow citizens
with the Saints and members of the household of God.
Built on the foundation of the Apostles and Prophets Christ.
Jesus himself being the Cornerstone.
In whom the whole structure being joined together grows
into a holy Temple in the Lord.
In him you also are being built together into a
dwelling place for God by the spirit.
God help us understand this help us see your peace
that shows up in daily life
as well.
And Jesus name help us.
amen
And so what was the problem here?
As we look at this passage in this early church in Ephesus. What
was the problem?
Well, the problem was that you had people from Jewish backgrounds
who were believing in Christ coming to Faith In Jesus.
And then you also had people who are from non-jewish backgrounds believing
in Jesus coming to faith in Christ.
Which meant that that these people over here who were
historically ostracized by the Jews who had
been kept to the fringes of society and kept
to the fringes of worship.
We're now in the church together.
These people are once enemies once opposing groups
were now together and that made that potentially explosive
because there was not peace traditionally
between these two groups.
There was tolerance but there was no peace true
Unity here. There was not shalom.
There was merely division.
There was division that happened in life.
division among people here
and you see it right the language used in verse
12. He says separated alienated strangers.
Even verse 14 explicitly talks about this
dividing wall of hostility.
It's like East and West Germany, right? Remember that there was a dividing wall that
kept people apart from each other. That's a
lack of Shalom, right?
Israel had cast them off and said that because they did not
have God's covenant by God's law then
they were excluded.
Which actually was not just a Jewish Problem from
before Jesus this actually dripped into the church this
same thought process showed up where there
was a debate early in the church whether Gentile Believers
had to become Jewish to be Christians.
It's the whole book of Galatians you go read how this debate happened that
they need to go through these rituals to become Christians like hold up.
It was just this division among people.
That was the problem. It was division in the
world.
But it was even division within the church that Paul's addressing
here in Ephesians 2.
Well thankfully 2,000 years of progress has
solved this problem, right?
No, there is sadly so
much more division now that seems than ever
before.
Course, we have wars between nations happening around the world. But
but even on such basic things
like like politics and sports were so divided.
I can't even tell you the things that I heard on the sidelines. I
don't know away game.
Like no literally I can't repeat it. It's so bad like I would be
terrible.
Like here in these things about my mom. I'm like
guys it's just a game like come on, man.
Some of you even saw it in your family's last week at Thanksgiving, right?
As soon as your uncle brought up the economy, man, everything goes south
and nobody has any more fun.
Division is not gone from churches either.
We're preaching style or music style or clothing
choices become reasons people split congregations.
Or were some churches will show disdain for those who
don't look like or dress like or
think like the majority.
And so it becomes a very homogeneous group.
Now hear me. I'm not talking about when leaders abuse Trust.
or when
or when we have first tier issues like theological concerns
over the atonement or the deity
of Christ not talking about those things that we must
stand firm on absolutely.
I'm talking about second or even third level
issues where it might be harder to
come together because of preferences and backgrounds, but
we're commanded to come together on.
Doesn't mean we're all going to agree preferences, and we're
not all unanimous.
But Unity is what we're commanded to have.
but the reason
they're still division in the world.
The reason they're still division among people outside the
church even inside the church is because our modern society
has not Advanced past the source
of that disunity.
Which is our Wicked hearts.
It's in here.
This is the foundation behind all the other
problems in the world.
James 4 makes it very clear.
Verses 1 through 4, what causes corals and what causes
fights among you is it not this that your
passions your desires are at War
within you?
You desire and you do not have and so you murder.
You covet and cannot obtain and so you fight and
quarrel.
You do not have because you do not ask you ask
and don't receive because you ask wrongly to spend on
your own Passions.
You adulterous people?
Do you not know that friendship with the world is enmity with
God?
Therefore whoever wishes to be a friend of the world makes himself
an enemy of God.
selfish sin
is the reason there is war in the world. The reason
there's Strife in your family. The reason they're splits
in churches.
It's because of this inside of each one
of us.
And that's bad.
Carnage it hurts
But there's actually a deeper consequence here than any
of those other problems.
This those are bad but there's a deeper one. Not only do we have division among
people because of our sin James 4 even said now we
because of that have enmity with God.
Because of what's inside of us.
Because of our sin because of our selfishness brings enmity
with God.
And you saw it here in Ephesians 2 right over and
over this this separation from God because God
is Holy because God is separate. He's
different. He's other he's perfect and for
anyone to be with God we must be just like him.
We must be like him or we can't be with him.
Here's the problem though.
Beginning of Ephesians 2 verses 1 through 3 we read this.
You were dead in the trespasses and sins and what
you once walked following the course of this world which
James 4 said brings enmity with God, right?
Following the prince of the power of the air the spirit that is now
at work and the sons of Disobedience among whom we
all once lived in the passions of our flesh.
Carrying out the desires of the body and the mind
and were by Nature as a result of all of
that children of Wrath.
like the rest of mankind
meaning every one of us
and listen to be a child of Wrath means that
wrath is your inheritance.
It means that that wrath.
Towards sin is coming on you.
And your sin?
Because he's holy.
He must do something with sin.
And this is the problem for every one of us on our own.
And there's nothing we can do ourselves to to
fix the problem to overcome this issue to
gain access to God to bring peace to our
lives. We can't
but praise the Lord that he can.
Praise the Lord that he can because thankfully this
passage in Ephesians 2 not only describes the problem it also
explains the solution.
It gives us the solution to that
same problem of division among people of enmity
with God. It gives us the solution not just
a bad news. This is also the good news.
But notice here the solution had nothing to do
with human ingenuity.
And nothing to do with with our our education
improving or political situation improving. This
was a spiritual problem. So it needed a
spiritual solution.
And that's called the Messiah.
solution to this problem
that Ephesians 2 shows us
Is the messiah?
It is the Messiah the predicted one. They
were waiting for in the Old Testament. This this one
they were longing for.
The one we now know as Jesus.
This is the solution given the
solution to their problems and see what he
did. Right. Let's go back through see what he did to fix
their problems in Ephesians 2.
Verse 13 says he shed his blood to
bring near the Gentiles.
Instead of where they were before where they were kept outside the
temple.
Excluded now.
They had equal access to God's presence
Through jesus' Blood, not any
animal anymore or anything else that was all taken care of jesus' blood
brought Jews and Gentiles into the holy
place.
to God's very presence
He brought near the Gentiles and
then in verse 14 through 16. Jesus broken body
destroyed that dividing wall
of hostility.
He made these formerly separated groups
now one body.
Through his broken body in other words. He was shredded so
that we could be healed.
He was torn into pieces so
that we could be unified we could be completed
we could be whole.
shalom
his broken body brought about
Shalom for us.
And the final thing he said it says here in Ephesians
2 that Jesus did to fix the problems.
He provided acts in one Spirit
to the father both, Jew and
Gentile access to very God himself.
through the spirit
through his broken body through his blood and all of
that is true.
He fixed all the problems all that is true because of what verse 14
says about Jesus.
It says that he himself is our
peace.
That's the Greek version of that same word. We've looked at in Hebrew Old
Testament Shalom. This is the the Greek version of that that he
himself this this Messiah Savior.
Jesus is our peace.
This is the same thing that Isaiah predicted.
About the Messiah that would come in the Messiah.
He looked at this 700 years before Jesus showed up
and he predicted this Isaiah 9 verses 6
and 7.
He says this.
for to us a child is born to
us a son is given and the government
shall be upon his shoulder his name Shall be Called
wonderful counselor, Mighty God Everlasting father Prince
of
peace shalom
of the increase of his government and of
Peace there will be no end.
On the throne of David over his kingdom to establish it to uphold it
with Justice with righteousness from this time forth and forevermore.
The Zeal of the Lord of hosts will do this.
He himself.
Prince of Peace is our peace. It's
what Jesus was was declared to be
even by the Angels who showed up the night. He was born they they
came to these dirty Shepherds out on the
fields and he says they they shout this glory to
God in the highest and on Earth. Peace.
Among those with whom he is pleased.
That's what Jesus himself said.
He was going to give his followers unlike anything the
world would offer John 14:27. Jesus says, peace
I leave with you.
my peace
not the world's peace. They can't do anything. Nothing can do this.
My peace. I give to you. Nothing else
hear me. Nothing else can give you the peace your
longing for.
even the situation you're worried about fixing working
out all that you think it should be
Will not give you the peace that you long for.
It's only found in Jesus himself as
our peace.
But that peace he is that he brings all that.
It does something.
Here it does something in Ephesians chapter 2.
What are the results we see here?
From this Messiah being our peace. What are the
results that we see very clearly?
Well, here's the first result we see from Jesus being our peace.
The first result in Ephesians 2 is that we now have
and can have eternal peace with God.
So this Messiah coming that we're waiting for that
they were waiting for he brings peace with
God.
Sal Romans 5 describes it so well
verses 1 and 2 say since we have been justified by
faith. We have peace with God through our
Lord Jesus Christ.
Through him we have obtained access by faith
into this grace in which we stand and
we rejoice in Hope of the
glory of God.
See, this is what the Old Testament saints were longing for.
This is what they were waiting for is this full consistent
piece with and access to
God himself. That's what they wanted.
Because they didn't have it. They had to go to the temple they had to to wait. They
were they were longing for this. They didn't see it in full form around
them and they were waiting for this consistent piece.
They're waiting for this Messiah to come and bring that Shalom back.
That they once had back in the Garden of Eden
that they once had in the promised land in some form they were
waiting for peace again.
To restore the wholeness.
Of the broken relationships that they had between themselves each
other and their creator.
Unbeliever, this is the aching you feel deep down in your soul.
Is something's off.
And you can't find a way to fix it.
It's this.
peace with God
But did you see what Romans 5:1 said the only way we can get that
peace with God.
It says through being justified by faith.
It's a legal term. That means being set, right.
And it goes back to Ephesians 2. We're continuing on right
before what we just read Ephesians 2:8 and 9.
It says that by Grace you have been saved through
faith.
And this is not your own doing it is the gift of God
not a result of works so that no
one may both.
Now kids Christmas is coming up.
You don't earn your gifts, right?
At least parents. I hope not that's it. Let's have a conversation about that if
you if you are but kids right you don't earn your
gifts.
If you if you had to earn your gifts, they stop
being gifts. They become a wage. It becomes something you earn.
Or you lose?
No with a gift you simply receive a gift
you're trusting that The Giver of
that gift is good and they are giving you something good.
That's what you trust in receiving a gift.
But like some of you did I I grew up
in church my whole life.
Here's what here's what I fear happens for many of us in that
situation.
Here's what I worry. We believe wrongly about this
regarding salvation.
First I fear that we somehow wrongly believe
that we deserve that gift.
of salvation
And we're not really that bad.
And sure God looked into the world and said
man, they're they're decent human being I should save them
get them on my team. Right like somehow we we think that that's
where we're better than the jerk down the street or jerk at
school like we we're okay we deserve this, right?
or maybe
we wrongly believe that.
Man, we better keep our nose clean so we can keep that
gift.
And there's this fear creeping over your shoulder that
you're always about to lose that gift of selfish
that God's about to snatch it away from you because you just
did too much.
You went too far this time.
But I can't do you see here.
God's heart in Ephesians 2 that his
desire
his heart is to bring us near to
himself.
That he he wants those who were without hope in
the world those who are without God in the world. He says
come near to me.
Let me let me reconcile you. Let me
give you access to God. Let me adopt you into my
family. Let me dwell inside of you. What Grace here.
This is the kind of peace with God.
Through the Messiah that those Old Testament saints were
longing for.
It's what we all need.
To know that confidently not to not to walk
around and prideful arrogance not to walk around in fear.
It's to walk around in confident humble. Peace
with God through Jesus in our
place.
It's what we all need but it's also hear me.
It's also what we are we're hopeful and
anticipating and longing for in the future that will come one
day in full.
Because again, we're not living in full. Peace yet. Are we?
There's still Brokenness. There's still chaos. There's still things
that we we choose to do that that sort of lead us away
from that peace with God that we feel daily, but
what we're longing for
What we're longing for church is what what is coming someday where
everything that threatens that shalom in
our lives will one day be removed.
All the external and internal forces that threaten shalom
in our lives will one day be removed. It's what
Revelation 21 three through five describes where he
looks into heaven and he says Behold The
Dwelling Place of God is with man.
Perfect. Peace with God face to face
with our creator he will dwell with them. They will
be his people God himself will be with them as their God.
He'll wipe away every tear from their eyes Death
Shall be no more neither shall there be
mourning nor crying nor pain anymore for the former things
have passed away.
And he who is Seated on the throne said behold? I
am making all things new unbelievers
don't you want that too?
Like we all as Believers long for that day. We know that's
coming and we we have a hope for that day, but unbeliever
don't you want that to
There's a hope in you. There's a aching in you for
that same thing.
It's only found in Jesus.
He himself.
is our peace
peace with God is essential both now
and forever.
But there's actually one other result in Ephesians 2 of this Advent.
this Messiah
it's this.
Unity among people
So what was once division?
Among people now in the Messiah there
can be Unity.
It can be Unity among people in Jesus.
Like when you go back and read Ephesians 2:11 through 22 and you
think through what what the Apostle Paul was writing here.
It seems like he goes out of his way to describe
the feeling the Gentiles must have felt
as they were excluded from the Jewish traditions.
These words that describe the separation for so
long. But what that does is it only magnifies the
gracious Unity that Jesus himself brings
in light of that.
I mean just look back through this verse 13 He says they who
are once far off have now been brought near.
Verse 14. He made them both one new man.
In verse 15 abolished broke down the wall
of the ceremonial law that used to divide them. He
says what was once divided now, you're back verse 16.
He reconciled them together in one body through
the cross Verse 18, they both have access to the
father through Jesus in the spirit.
verse 19 no longer foreigners now fellow citizens
leading to verses 20 to 22. Which describe how God is
making his church his new Dwelling Place.
Where all these pieces that were once chaos and Scattered are
now joined together perfectly.
And his his word his his Christ is
the foundation.
And it brings Shalom right like that puzzle. Chaos now
pictured perfect. It's shalom.
See this whole Passage.
It paints a beautiful Colossians 3:11
you go read that later Colossians 3:11 picture of
unity in the church this restored.
Grace of unity
through jesus' life death and Resurrection
Which also means that Jews and Gentiles and what he's
talking about Ephesus that was happening the unity was happening. It was hard but
it was happening which means that that kind of unity is
something that we can experience today as well.
If it's through Jesus if it's through the gospel.
Through the spirit. We have the ability for the
same kind of unity today even.
Even in the many nationalities represented Among Us
in this church.
Even as those from diverse backgrounds who
didn't grow up in church like me didn't grow up in a
safe family like you like even from diverse
backgrounds who who understand the gospel plug
in here even among that. There's Unity even
as we share peace with the downcast and the outcast out there
even as we go and and see God bring more
people because the gospel still the same
as it was in Ephesus, then we can have Unity no
matter what
No matter what. We're facing no matter what differences we
have. It's just going to take some Hig puff to
maintain it.
I know some of you're like, what did he just say? What what
is that?
Let me describe. It's been a couple years of this journey for
us as a church, but higpuff is an acronym we use to show
what we do to maintain Unity higpuff humility
gentleness patience forbearance.
That's what it is humility generals patience and forbearance,
and it comes from Ephesians chapter 4.
Just a page to the right. Maybe it's what we find in verses
1 through 3 and you'll hear it here.
That in light of the Gospel again. Paul says
I a prisoner of the Lord.
Urge you to walk in a manner worthy of
the calling to which you've been called with all humility and
gentleness with patience bearing with
one another in love or forbearance.
Eager to maintain the unity
of the spirit in the bond of peace.
There's that word again. Peace.
There's the that's the the glue that holds us
together. Right? It's peace in Jesus.
He himself is our peace, but now it's up
to us.
The spirit's already given us Unity. It says he's
he's welding us together like two
metals.
It's up to us to maintain that Unity is what it says.
eagerly maintaining it through higpuff
Now again, like I said before it doesn't mean we're going to agree on every
preference doesn't mean we're ever Oregon's gonna
agree on every way. We should do certain things in here
or in the world. It just means we don't fight
each other we fight for Unity.
We fight for Unity in the midst of the diversity.
And think about how these four qualities higpuff help
maintain unity in the church. Just hear
these humility.
What that means is that I'm putting you ahead of
myself.
What if you walked in here what if every one of us walked in
here on a Sunday and thought about more what everybody
else likes?
or enjoys
what if as we think about gentleness?
Which means that I'm not going to fly off the handle when I disagree with
you.
When I don't get in my way, what if what if
we were always calm in our responses towards one another?
in the church
or even online
and gentleness
flowing out of us
patience
patience means I'm going to give you the benefit of the doubt.
And give you time and space to grow.
And so what if we walked around in our lives assuming the
best of others?
the best intentions the best motivations
Now I get trust to understand that there's a level of
that that we need to continue to build. But what if we just assumed the
best?
And we're patient.
And the f is forbearance which in the
text is bearing with one other in love. That means I'm going
to forgive you when you blow it because I
love you.
And I'm trusting God to change you.
Not me.
God to change you.
I'm bearing with you in love.
Because I know God's working.
Think about each one of us having that
higpuff attitude.
Would that not Foster Unity within the church?
Absolutely. What?
But again, we can only do that.
We can only do that if we have peace with God ourselves.
Individually each one of us having peace with God if we have been
put back together in shalom.
If the chaos of Our Lives has
been restored in Jesus.
Now, I know I say that perfect. Peace is still future.
There will still be disagreements there will still be tiffs. There will
still be issues. There will still be things that happen in the world. But the beauty of
this Messiah is that he now brings
a foretaste of that Glory Divine in
our lives even today.
So we have glimpses and feelings of
Hope and peace and joy and love
showing up because of Jesus even today.
but one day
in full we long for that day.
And so so you might be sitting here today.
In your life is chaos.
And you've tried everything to try to fix it.
And you know you don't have peace with God right now.
You know, this is not describing you. What
do you do with that you turn from your sin and yourself and
you turn to Jesus in your place?
You receive this gift of Salvation at
Christmas.
What better gift?
That's that's if you feel that right now you
turn to the one who he himself is your peace
you turn to him. But then once you have that.
And for those of us who do believe.
We are now called to live out that Shalom
here on Earth.
To be what Jesus said in Matthew 5 to be peacemakers.
Shalom makers
now again, the only way we can do that is in his
power alone him doing that through us as we abide
in him. But but this this peacemaking, this
is how the world around us gets a taste
of Eternity.
That's how they just they they start to see Shalom happen
because because the world isn't showing that how do they see
it? They see it in us and through us.
Where Jesus being our peace?
Means we bring a wholeness to those who
are entrapped in poverty. For example.
And we show the world a diverse Church
unified around the gospel. They're like,
wow. I've never seen that before or you start to humble
yourself and you confront somebody over a sin,
but then you end up with a deeper relationship when they
walk in Repentance.
That's Shalom. That's that's wholeness coming
to the world.
When a man's broken over his addiction and he comes to you and you
you lead him to Jesus and he walks in
Humble repentance and you walk with him towards
wholeness in his life his family.
And on and on we could go of how the world sees peace
through us as we bring Shalom
to those around us. That's what happens as
people as people see the glory of God shine through
us. They see
shalom
they begin to long for that same peace
in their lives.
They longed to know the one.
As Ephesians 2:14 said they long to know the one who he
himself is our peace.
So let's wait on him for that and let's be that kind of people.
In light of his peace for us and that candle
today.
That candle of peace is what we're going to light this morning.
To remind us of how Jesus came to
bring peace and Jesus is our peace. We
lighted the candle of Hope on Wednesday night. And
today we'll add peace to it as the
second candle and invite the Adele family
up here today to lead us through that.
Josh is one of our deacons they co-lead a
community group both Josh and Jenny serve Faithfully
in many ways in our kids ministry.
And their family again is going to light the Hope candle and
then the peace candle as well and read
some scripture that points us to
the Messiah.
That brings us peace that Messiah who
is our peace. We will see it in.
scripture today
How beautiful upon the mountains are the
feet of him who brings good news who publishes peace
who brings good news of Happiness who publishes
salvation? He says to Zion your
god reigns the voice of your Watchman. They
lift up their voice together. They sing for Joy for
I to eye the return of the Lord to
Zion Break Forth together and singing
you waste places of Jerusalem for the Lord
has confronted his people.
He has redeemed Jerusalem. The Lord has
bared his holy arm before the eyes of all the
nations and all the ends of the Earth. Shall see the salvation
of our God.
Praise be to God.
Lord
Thank you.
Thank you for your blessing of peace.
Thank you for being our foundation.
being with us in times of joy
times of pain
Thank you that through Jesus we have access to
your peace which passes all understanding.
Lift up this congregation and our leadership.
Ask for you to guard our hearts and our minds
in Christ Jesus.
Pray for peace and unity among us so
we can better glorify you.
love others
share the gospel with others.
amen